Drop it!
Both your guns are empty.
So you've noticed.
(Text: "CONGRATS FOR STOMPIN' RATS")
Oh thanks, sweetie. Is that for me? Alright.
Yeah, totally sweet, right?
Bet you they don't show you this in third grade.
[imitating gun whooshing sounds]
[child laughing]
Freddie, keep a lid on your tricks.
Marisha's gonna see that.
Dude, so what?
"So what?"
You know how many sicks reloads I had to do to get her to marry me?
We've been on the rocks for months. I'm sick of reloading our marriage.
Please. No more reloads at my house.
It's not my fault she's smoking ho- !
Freddie!
Fine.
When we're getting our brewskis, we're going to pretend this conversation that never happened.
The pigs that busted our gang. They're here, right?
Yeah, this is it.
Oh God.
Hey boss, we're not gonna bring the bazooka?
We're clowns, you dipshit. We're not using it.
So why'd you pack the bazooka if we're not gonna bring it?
Which one of you idiots packed this bazooka?
[Inception BWAHH]
Hey, Freddie.
Oh. Uh, hey.
Ugh, I'm having trouble reloading this damn thing.
Could you please help me?
[Inception BWAHH]
Hot dogs! gawds!
Yeah. Sure, sure.
[Even more Inception BWAAHHS]
[fan whooshing]
Wait, can you help me get the TV working? I was trying to put the game on.
Think the batteries are dead.
Can you reload them?
When I tell you to, throw these batteries away into the trash!
But they're still good.
Trust me.
Now!
Alright, hot dogs are r—
Freddie...
Sports, y'know.
Freddie!
I was just putting on the game.
I saw what you were putting on!
Dude. She asked me to help.
How could you?
Niko.
It's not her fault, man.
No more reloads.
Fine.
Sacred promise on your mother's grave.
Under no circumstances will you ever reload my house ever again.
Fine.
[Bro Shake]
I promise I will never perform another sick-ass reload in your house ever again.
[Ding dong]
[Door break]
Reloading!
(echoed)
I—
Y—
You got this one, man.
I'm out!
𝘙𝘦𝘭𝘰𝘢𝘥𝘪𝘯𝘨!
Oh wow!
(slowed down)
AAAAARRRRGGGHHHH!!!
𝘚𝘢𝘤𝘳𝘦𝘥 𝘱𝘳𝘰𝘮𝘪𝘴𝘦...
𝘰𝘯 𝘺𝘰𝘶𝘳 𝘮𝘰𝘵𝘩𝘦𝘳'𝘴 𝘨𝘳𝘢𝘷𝘦...
[Bro Shake flashback]
𝘙𝘦𝘭𝘰𝘢𝘥𝘪𝘯𝘨...
[flashbang]
𝘐 𝘤𝘢𝘯'𝘵 𝘴𝘦𝘦!
What?! Imposs—
Honey!
You're my hero!
Are you hurt?
I'm fine.
Thanks, partner.
No problemo.
I do have one question, though.
If someone reloads in the woods and no one's around to see it, is it still Tacticool®?
Hell yeah, it is.
[stilted laughter]
YEAH!
[BRO SHAKE]
Hey, boss!
I assume you have the package.
We got it.
I have been waiting for this shipment of drugs and money for so long...
We don't have the drugs or money, but...
You're gonna love this!
The hell is this? How is this better than drugs?
You can get drugs and money at any time.
Any time.
You know, right down the street...
but what you can't get...
is this limited-edition...
500 unit only, long-sleeve, black t-shirt.
I mean streetwear 𝘢𝘯𝘥 street value.
Check this out.
They've never made a jacket before.
This is the first jacket they've ever made.
Everything on the store sells out...
in like one day, two days, sometimes even hours.
Whoo!
Gone!
You see this right here?
I'm wearing one of those right now.
You get high on your own supply?
Think about it this way.
You have a shirt on right now.
𝘐 have a shirt on right now.
I've got three shirts on right now!
And this shirt right here...
could be the shirt that we all have right now.
Drugs and money?
Everywhere.
But this merchandise will never be available again.
You see what I'm saying?
corridordigital.store